with fifty Shades of Grey out now let's
take a look at 25 things you probably
didn't know about the big screen version
of Yael James is a rhotic novel in order
to keep the Fifty Shades of Grey script
top secret during early auditions actors
were asked to prepare a scene from
another film Jamie Dornan who plays
Christian Grey chose a scene from the
90s movie true romance which was written
by Quentin Tarantino for her Fifty
Shades audition Dakota Johnson read a
four-page monologue from the 60s
psychological drama persona which is
written and directed by Ingmar Bergman
Johnson's performance of this particular
piece allowed the filmmakers to see she
was capable of bringing to life and his
emotional journey in Fifty Shades of
Grey Jamie Dornan said the scene he most
enjoyed filming was the first time that
Christian and Anna meet which the
filmmakers shot over two days to help
them develop a believable
mother-daughter bond Dakota Johnson and
Jennifer Ely who plays Anna's mother
would chat on the phone while Johnson
was on set and Ely was at home the
actresses found this particularly
helpful as most of Anna and her mother's
communication takes place over the phone
Fifty Shades of Grey was shot in the
Canadian city of Vancouver which doubled
for the book setting in the u.s. cities
of Seattle and Vancouver and Washington
State and Portland Oregon and although
the story set in summer time filming
actually took place in winter the
filmmakers kept the details of what they
were filming and were as quiet as
possible they did this to avoid roads
and streets becoming crowded with
onlookers which could have led to
expensive delays to their tight
production schedule use of the title
Fifty Shades of Grey was banned on set
and in any correspondence or printed
materials connected with the film
instead the crew used the fake name the
adventure of Max and banks Max is the
name of Al James's dog and banks is the
name of screenwriter Kelly Marcel's
puppy there were 55 locations in the
movies final shooting schedule the
Fairmount hotel in Vancouver Canada
doubled for the Heathman hotel in
Portland Oregon while the University of
British Columbia
stood in for Washington State University
Anna and Christians first date at a
coffee shop was filmed in the Gastown
district of Vancouver in Canada which
doubled for Portland Ladner village
hardware which is located in a small
town about 45 minutes from Vancouver was
chosen to represent Clayton's hardware
store where Anna works while in college
when production designer David Wasco
first met with director Sam
taylor-johnson the pair discovered
they'd each independently chosen the
same photograph as a reference shot for
the tone and luck of Fifty Shades of
Grey the photograph was by fashion
photographer Helmut Newton from his book
white women author EL James drew a floor
plan of Christians penthouse to help
production designer David Weiss go get
to grips with the layout of Christians
home in the Fifty Shades trilogy to
Vancouver houses built a quarter of a
mile apart for entrepreneurial brothers
in the 1920s feature in the film to make
sure they gave the homes the right look
for the story setting the movies design
team researched
upper end Seattle homes one of the homes
was used for the exterior of Christians
family residence as well as its foyer
and dining room while the second home
was used for its glass enclosed swimming
pool which appears instead of the books
boathouse sets were built for Christians
penthouse including the living room
kitchen dining room his bedroom Anna's
bedroom and of course the Red Room they
concealed the set by building them on
stages so preventing people from seeing
them and the whole build covered three
stages to create the look of Christians
penthouse the filmmakers used as a point
of reference the work of architects
including Norman Foster
John parson and Hugh Neal Jacobson
thanks to her background as an artist
director Sam taylor-johnson was able to
secure paintings by artists including
Ezra Shay and John Baldessari
to display in the offices of Christian
Grey the work of many other artists also
appears in the film
as does one of the directors own pieces
the most challenging and revealing
scenes between Christian and Anna were
kept till the end of the shoot so the
scenes in Christians infamous Red Room
were shot during the last two weeks of
filming Dakota Johnson wanted her
reaction to the Red Room to be as
genuine as possible so the very first
time she saw it was when her character
Anna sees it for the first time in the
movie the height and the impact of the
Red Room the filmmakers limited the use
of red and black in the movie except for
graduation gowns at Washington State
University's graduation ceremony to make
sure they got the look of the Red Room
just-right production designer David
Weiss go and set decorator sandy Wasco
consulted the experts in other words
dominate receives with Christian Grey
type clients one of the things they
discovered was that leather is the best
floor covering because of all the
kneeling people do author EL James was
also quite specific about the rooms
layout and director Sam taylor-johnson
was quite particular about its
appearance for example taylor-johnson
wanted the room to reference high-end
stables so the design team went for
brown leather and wood equipment as
opposed to the black often favored in
such rooms much of the furniture and
equipment seen in the Red Room was
custom made in England to research his
character Christian Grey Jamie Dornan
visited a sex dungeon to watch a session
between a dominant and a submissive a
great deal of care was taken over the
design of Christian Grey's clothes the
filmmakers discussed issues such as a
type of cuffs collars and lapels the
weight of the fabric and the amount of
patterning all but one of the suits worn
by Jamie Dornan were handmade and all of
his shirts were also custom made costume
designer mark bridges was very specific
about Christians ties the thickness the
sturdiness and of course how gray they
were all of Christians infamous silver
ties were specifically designed and
painstakingly handmade
costume designer Marc bridges designed a
peach silk and chiffon dress for Anna
which echoes an iconic dress worn by
Faye Dunaway in the 1968 film the Thomas
Crown Affair all 30l James set a
challenge for the movies property master
Dan seasons for the scene were Christian
and Alice sure SH am pane after her
graduation
James shows Sissons a photo of a pair of
antique tea cups she owns and asked him
if he could find them or something
similar for the scene the cups are
actually over 100 years old and the
company that made them no longer exists
but property master Sissons
managed to track down six identical cups
which arrived on set just 48 hours after
his conversation with James Christian
Grey has out his latest fleet of cars at
his disposal including the r8 sports car
the s8 sedan cruiser and the brand-new
a3 which he gives to Anna as a gift
although the latest model a3 wasn't
available to buy until after filming
ended the filmmakers managed to secure
it for their shoot Christian's ec130
helicopter Charlie Tango is the largest
helicopter that can be privately owned
and costs around two million dollars for
the movie the art department fully
customized the ec130 including its
graphics so they fit the designs found
elsewhere in Christians professional
world Sam taylor-johnson directed the
music video for earned it
by Canadian singer-songwriter the
weekened which features in Fifty Shades
of Grey the music video features Dakota
Johnson and the work of Fifty Shades of
Grey cinematographer Seamus McGarvey
well there you have it 25 things you
probably didn't know about Fifty Shades
of Grey
now tell me what's your favorite
big-screen adaptation if you enjoyed
this video hit the thumbs up button and
subscribe for more things you didn't
know and weekly movie reviews and
interviews
thanks for watching yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers